did you know that two out of every three guys
are going to experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 i definitely know
for me i was around 25 when i started to lose all
of my hair i wish keeps a bit around when i was
younger because advancements in science meant
that there are now treatments that can combat the
symptoms of hair loss and help you keep the hair
that you have look it's too late for me my hair's
not coming back but you don't have to be like me
you can stop your hair loss early thanks to
keeps keeps off as generic versions of the only
two fda-approved drugs for treating hair
loss so you may have tried them before
but never at a price this low that's right
if you were thinking oh boy this is some
sort of medicine it's about to get extremely
expensive well you couldn't be more wrong
because keep starts are just dollars a
month how does it work well for one thing
there's no need to visit a doctor's office just
schedule a quick online consult and a bit later
discreet package is going to arrive at your door
and you can use it in the privacy of your own home
so if you're noticing that you're losing your hair
that's one problem that's not gonna fix itself
do something about it so for a limited time you
go to keeps.com forward slash biographics or
click the link in the description below and you'll
get 50 off your first order and now today's video
in the 18th century much of the world was still
unknown to european civilization as shipbuilding
and navigation technology improved trade routes
expanded from the great cities of europe across
the globe countries played a game of empire
building setting out to find new lands to claim
for themselves gambling that as yet undiscovered
islands and even entire continents would hold vast
riches for them to exploit to accomplish this they
needed explorers daring ship captains that had no
qualms about being tens of thousands of miles from
home alone in a vast ocean who could navigate the
unknowns and return to port to tell their
discoveries perhaps the best known of these
explorers was captain james cook who embarked on
three different expeditions that spanned 12 years
filling in much of the map of the pacific ocean
with his discoveries his adventures read like
a robert louis stevenson novel complete with
surviving vicious storms and near shipwrecks
battling tribes of hostile natives setting foot
in places no european had ever been before and
returning home to become an international hero
cook's one major flaw was that he let his fame
go to his head he truly began to believe
his own hype and it eventually led to his
spectacular and sudden downfall that is just
as famous as his globe spanning adventures
james cook was born on the 7th of november 1728
in a small village in yorkshire england his father
also named james was a farmer having risen to the
lofty position of foreman at the largest estate in
the region his son might have been expected to
follow in his father's footsteps and thus would
have disappeared into history but that was not
his destiny as it quickly became clear that young
james was not suited for farm work in 1746 after
leaving an apprenticeship at a grocery store the
young james traveled to whitby a prominent port
city where he was introduced to the owner of a
merchant fleet taken on as a siemens apprentice it
appeared that he had found his life's calling cook
took to sailing with gusto not only learning the
technical side of the trade but also the academic
teaching himself the advanced mathematics and
astronomy needed for navigation this allowed him
to quickly rise through the ranks of the merchant
marines until by 1755 his employers were ready to
offer him the captaincy of one of their ships cook
would have been set for life earning a comfortable
living in a respected profession in society but
that wonderlust that would follow cook all his
life to seek out new horizons hit him again and
to the astonishment of everyone who knew him
he rejected the promotion and instead decided to
join the royal navy as an able seaman cook must
have made an odd sight among his shipmates aboard
the hms eagle when he came aboard and when they
discovered he'd given up a career in the merchant
navy to become one of them they probably thought
he was just a bit insane royal navy sailors
were jealous of their merchant counterparts they
were generally better paid lived in less cramped
and feted quarters spent more time at home and
usually weren't subject to the overbearingly harsh
discipline commonly imposed by military officers
of the period in addition royal navy officers were
almost always the well-to-do sons of the landed
gentry who had been serving aboard warships since
before they'd gone through puberty james cook with
his humble background and late start seemed to
stand little chance of ever commanding a ship
it just didn't seem possible in the rigid class
structure of 18th century britain nonetheless cook
superiors quickly took notice of his intelligence
and experience and plucked him out of the depths
of the ship and within two years he'd been
promoted to sailing master responsible for
navigating the ship a very important role and
likely as high as he would ever be able to rise
within the royal navy cook saw action during the
seven years war against france and played a key
role in the siege of quebec when he surveyed
and mapped the entrance of the saint lawrence
river allowing british general wolf to launch his
famous surprise assault that captured the city
recognized for his navigational and cartographic
skill cook was commissioned to chart the coast
of newfoundland which consumed most of his time
over the course of the next five years his maps of
the island were so thorough that they were still
being used by sailors 200 years after he made them
once he completed his survey of newfoundland cook
returned to britain and his wife elizabeth who had
married in 1762. despite the long years he spent
away from her it was apparent that he loved his
wife deeply and flaunted the traditional notion
of a sailor having a girl in every port by never
being unfaithful to her in 1768 though
it seemed like james is going to have
a lot of time to spend with elizabeth in
their london home because his naval career
appeared to have stalled not currently a war the
royal navy was being drawn down and there were few
positions available even for a talented man like
cook it was at this point that fortune smiled on
cook through a remarkable set of circumstances the
royal society was britain's scientific authority
and they were excited by an upcoming astronomical
event that promised great potential for scientific
advancement on the 3rd of june 1769 the planet
venus would cross the face of the sun in the
earth's sky by accurately charting the precise
time that the transit of venus began and ended
from different points around the earth it was
believed that it would be possible to precisely
calculate the earth's distance from the sun
what is today known as an astronomical unit
au one of the points it was decided to observe
the transit of venus from was the newly discovered
pacific island of tahiti and the royal society
proposed a voyage there a young scientist named
joseph banks was deeply interested in the voyage
for reasons that had nothing to do with astronomy
banks was a botanist largely self-taught because
of a teenage fascination with plants that had
parlayed into a career it had certainly helped
that he had a sizable inheritance to fall back
on though banks figured that if he led the
expedition to tahiti he'd discover hundreds
if not thousands of new plants and animal species
and become a household name he went to one of his
influential friends the earl of sandwich for help
in sponsoring the voyage sandwich was interested
in the idea for his own reasons it had been
a long-held dream of his for a british ship
to be the first to discover the fabled southern
continent that was supposed to be situated on the
bottom of the world to counterbalance the land in
the northern hemisphere scientists had convinced
themselves that antarctica was a boundless land
of plenty chock full of natural resources to
enrich whoever broke through the treacherous
southern ocean to find it first there was no
reason he thought that a single voyage could
not fulfill everyone's purposes at once but
there was a problem the royal society believing
the voyage to be primarily scientific in nature
wanted one of their own to command the expedition
banks himself coveted the posting the royal navy
balked at the idea insisting that any ship sent to
the pacific would be commanded by a naval officer
banks hit on what he thought would be a compromise
he would advocate for a senior non-commissioned
officer to command the voyage one that had the
requisite navigational and cartographic experience
but lacked the social standing that banks did
so banks could effectively tell him what to do
without being formally in command a friend of
sandwiches had just the man in mind james cook
and so it was that cook out of nowhere was
promoted to first lieutenant and given command of
the expedition aboard the hms endeavour the ship
left port in august 1768 making a stop in brazil
before making the treacherous trip around the
tip of south america cape horn now in the pacific
endeavour headed north to tahiti along the way he
endured a private battle of wills with banks who
tried to enact his plan to take command of the
expedition banks was sent undercut by frequent
bouts of seasickness it being difficult to issue
commands when you are constantly throwing up and
any credibility he had left was destroyed when
a shore expedition he led went wrong and two of
the men froze to death no one would ever question
cook's command again endeavour arrived in tahiti
in april 1769 and spent weeks there preparing
to observe the transit of venus it was here that
james cook encountered the native polynesians for
the first time he adopted a paternalistic view of
them believing them to be noble but simple savages
that needed to be guided by men of reason such as
himself cook would eventually believe himself to
be an expert in the native tribes of the pacific
making attempts to learn their language
and customs but his incomplete knowledge
and dismissive attitude towards them
would come back to haunt him one day
after observing the transit endeavour
headed southwest looking for antarctica
they didn't find it of course and after a while
cook turned west intending to sail around the
previously unexplored new zealand it was cook
who discovered that new zealand is actually made
up of two different islands with what is now
known as cook strait separating them endeavour
sailed around both islands cooked charting
and naming places as he went along before
heading west and doing the same thing to the
eastern coastline of australia then known
as new holland nearly being shipwrecked in the
process after the ship ran around on the great
barrier reef after surviving that endeavour
sailed for home arriving in july 1771. the
voyage was considered a sensational success banks
had collected over 30 000 specimens of plants
during the voyage leading to the discovery of 1
300 new species a 25 increase in the amount of
known flora at the time cooked circumnavigated
the globe and charted places never seen before
by europeans and in the process had not lost
a single man to scurvy the dreaded scourge of
18th century sailing that would later be traced
to severe vitamin c deficiency cook found that
feeding a sailor's fresh food whenever possible
and in particular citrus fruits and sauerkraut
kept his sailors healthy though it would take
decades for the royal navy to start implementing
this in the rest of their fleet but cook still
hadn't found antarctica and to make matters worse
banks had used a sustained publicity campaign to
make himself out as the hero of the expedition
reducing cook to a mere footnote so after a year
ashore in england cook was ready to try again
discovering and claiming the proposed great
southern continent was a growing obsession
for king george iii in the early part of the
1770s so in 1772 the royal navy promoted cook and
gave him a new mission bind antarctica however
long it took for this voyage cook was to be
in command of two ships hms resolution and
hms adventure initially joseph banks was to
accompany cook on this second trip to the pacific
but after banks's proposed modifications to the
resolution for his own comfort proved liable to
capsize the ship in heavy seas they were scrapped
banks threw a fit and refused to go probably
thinking the admiralty would cave to his
demands and was therefore very surprised when
they simply found other scientists to go in
his stead cook's expedition got underway in
july 1772 heading down the coast of africa to
cape town to resupply before the two ships made
their first attempt to head south becoming the
first vessels known to have crossed the antarctic
circle they began to encounter sea ice the farther
south they went and cook eventually turned
back because he feared the ice water would
either smash his ship to pieces or freeze them in
place leaving his men to starve or freeze to death
this was another unexpected scientific discovery
until now it was thought that it wasn't possible
for saltwater to freeze cook headed for the
pacific running into problems with the captain
of the adventure tobias furno cook was incensed
to discover that men aboard the adventure were
getting sick and dying of scurvy because furno
was not following the dietary regimen that cooked
prescribed burnout probably wasn't the best
choice to serve as cook's lieutenant on this
voyage eventually the two vessels were separated
from each other inferno lost his nerve after
some of his men were killed and eaten by maori
cannibals in new zealand he sailed for home
abandoning the mission cook meanwhile seemed
determined to see every inch of the pacific
for himself he sailed in a wide meandering
circle that took him across polynesia and
melanesia and he made another attempt to find
antarctica reaching 71 degrees south latitude
before finding his path completely blocked by
sea ice a record that stood for decades he made
one more attempt in the south atlantic discovering
south georgia and the south sandwich islands but
no antarctica cook concluded that if the great
southern continent existed at all it was entirely
contained in the deep southern latitudes that
were covered year-round in ice even if they were
discovered they wouldn't be worth anything with
that question answered he sailed for home arriving
in july 1775. this time around cook didn't have
to share the spotlight with anybody he was great
britain's foremost adventurer a celebrity known
all over the western world he had done something
nobody had done before circa navigated the globe
at extreme southerly latitudes braving terrifying
storms and hostile natives in the process cook
enjoyed his newfound fame doing the 18th century
equivalent of the talk show circuit by accepting
invitations to dinners at wealthy mansions and
regaling his hosts with his adventures the
royal navy promoted him to post-captain and
at his request put him out to pasture placing him
in charge of the royal navy hospital in greenwich
which served as a retirement home for sailors
cook himself seemed destined for retirement
in 1776 king george and his government
had more pressing concerns than antarctica
war was the american colonies threatened to
disrupt the transatlantic trade which was
the lifeblood of the british empire for the earl
of sandwich now first lord of the admiralty it was
more important than ever to cultivate new trade
links wherever they could the biggest prize was
the so-called northwest passage route around the
north american continent from the atlantic to the
pacific ocean this route would save thousands
of miles on a sea trip from europe to asia
and would avoid the hazardous trips around
the southern tips of south america and africa
there was only one problem while everyone was
convinced that a northwest passage existed
no one had ever actually found it the
passage was so important to the king
that he offered a staggering prize of twenty
thousand pounds worth almost fifty million
dollars in today's money to the first man
who found it the fortune on offer proved too
tempting for cook to resist and he volunteered
himself to sandwich to lead the expedition
sandwich was only too happy to have lured his
old friend now the world's most famous explorer
out of retirement hms resolution would again
serve as cook's flagship for the voyage with a
second ship hms discovery replacing the adventure
cook departed from great britain in july 1776.
no one knew it at the time but the sea captain
would never see his homeland or his family again
the official purpose of cook's voyage was to
return amay a polynesian man who had been taken to
europe during cook's last journey back to his home
in tahiti once this was done cook could turn his
attention to his actual objective the northwest
passage in december 1777 cook left tahiti and
headed north making for the california coastline
it was during this trip that he first came across
the island in the middle of the pacific that no
european had ever seen before he had discovered
the northernmost hawaiian islands cook spent most
of the rest of 1778 trying to find the northwest
passage sailing through the bering strait and
charting the coastline of alaska in the process
eventually he found his path blocked by ice and
turned back cook wanted to make another attempt
the next year hoping that making the attempt in
summer would provide a route through the ice but
first he needed a place to spend the winter so he
headed back to hawaii in november they sighted the
island of maui and soon after the big island of
hawaii after exploring these new lands for two
months resolution and discovery dropped anchor
on the southwestern coast of hawaii by pure
chance cook's arrival coincided with the native
hawaiian harvest festival celebrating lono the god
of the harvest there is some speculation that the
hawaiians thought cook was the personification of
lono there to visit them which would explain the
initial excitement surrounding his visit before
long however relations between cook's crew and
the natives had deteriorated significantly and
both sides were happy to see the two ships
depart from the bay after a month to return
to the beiring sea however soon after leaving
they were caught in a storm and the foremast on
the resolution broke off and cook returned to
the bay for repairs for the hawaiians this was
an unexpected and unwelcome surprise and it set
off a chain of events that would end in violence
on all three of his trips cook had to deal with
native polynesians and malanesians stealing
things from his crew he did not understand that
the natives had a very different definition of
property than the europeans and felt that
since cook's ships had so much extra stuff
with them they shouldn't mind sharing
it with the people who didn't have it
over time cook began to retaliate against the
natives in even more harsh ways from kidnapping
tribal elders to ransom them back for the stolen
items to flogging the offenders with a bullwhip
on this particular trip however cooker descended
into outright barbarism in an attempt to deter
thievery by the natives during a three-month stay
in tonga cook adored dozens of natives lashed and
when that didn't work he started cutting off ears
shooting natives and then forcing them to try and
swim to shore beating them with boat ors and other
blunt objects and in at least one case he had a
cross cut into a man's arm going all the way down
to the bone many of cook's crew were veterans of
his previous voyage and was shocked by his marked
change in demeanor from previous trips not only
was he less patient and more savage than native
populations they came across but the usually
careful man was making mistakes in judgment and
spent more and more time sequestered in his cabin
cook was probably ill for great stretches of
the voyage complaining in his journal of a
stomach ailment among other things but at least
part of it was his oversized ego he was the
great man the discoverer of the whole of the
pacific and everyone should listen to what he
had to say the hawaiians were unimpressed by cook
and his men at this point and two days after the
ship's return to the bay one of the resolution's
longboats was stolen by the hawaiians to get the
boat back cook decided on an old standby he would
kidnap the most important chief of the island
and hold him for ransom the next day the 14th
february 1779 cook put his plan into action he
rode ashore with the ship's detachment of raw
marines in tow and set out for the chief's hut
the chief was still asleep when he was awakened
by cook and politely asked to accompany him back
to his ship believing that he was being asked
to visit the ship as a guest the chief complied
one of his wives however realized something was
wrong and followed the party to the beach wailing
for help this alerted other chiefs to the trouble
who came to the scene with their warriors by the
time cook and his men reached the beach they were
being followed by hundreds of increasingly angry
hawaiians the captured chief suddenly realized
that he was being kidnapped and refused to get
into the row boat sitting down in the sand
instead cook's attempt to manhandle the chief
only made the crowd more angry at this point cook
should have realized that he was outnumbered and
let the chief go discretion being the better
part of valor the cook was so used to getting
his way with the natives he'd encountered on
his adventures that he made the fatal decision
to persist with his intimidation tactics no one
is exactly sure what started the fight there are
multiple accounts from different people what
is known is that a general melee broke out in
which four royal marines and at least a dozen
hawaiians were killed at the center of it all
was james cook the famous sea captain was knocked
at the ground and then stabbed in the chest with a
metal dagger ironically given to the hawaiians as
gift weeks earlier as the remaining marines fled
for their lives and the two ships started firing
on the crowd with their cannons the hawaiians took
turns stabbing cook's body over and over again
they passed the dagger from one person to another
each getting a turn to plunge it into his flesh
cook was dead long before they finally ceased
cook's body was dragged off the beach and placed
in a roasting pit until his flesh had been
cooked off his bones they were pulled out and
buried in secret caves all over the islands
four of the most powerful chiefs ate
cook's heart to absorb his manner
his power the only bits of the captain's
body recovered by the crew of the resolution
were his hands and part of his skull which
were buried at sea the expedition carried
on undercooked subordinates and made another
attempt to find the northwest passage but again
they were foiled by the ice pack blocking the
way the two ships slowly made their way back home
reaching britain in october 1780. by then news of
the death of cook had already reached london and
all of europe was shocked by the dramatic
death of the world's most famous explorer
cook's posthumously published journals were
a literary sensation and captain cook remains
a cultural touchstone even in the 21st century
as pirate captain james hook from peter pan and
starship enterprise captain james kirk are both
named after him from historical standpoint cook
has a very mixed legacy on the one hand he was
a renowned explorer who filled in great swaths
of the world map on the other his brutal treatment
of the native populations he encountered served as
a forewarning of the kinds of barbarity that
would come from the eventual colonization of
these islands by europeans so i really hope you
found that video interesting if you did please
do hit that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and as always thank you for watching